[Music]
I know a lot of you have a different
version of this but in Hmong culture I
eat this with sticky rice instead of hot
pepper so you'll need a slab of pork
belly with the skin on this one is two
and a half pounds oil on medium heat for
about 15 minutes and make sure you move
the hair I should have done this earlier
as soon as you take it out poke the skin
all over and puncture it but you also
don't want to go too deep I went over
the skin several times just remember
that the more holes there are the
crispier it'll be I'm keeping it simple
and just seasoning with salt and then
you want to cover the bottom and sides
of aluminum foil and this is going to
keep the meat juicy dry the skin really
really well so it can crisp up later
brush with vinegar and bake at 375 for
about an hour 45 and then brush with
more vinegar and boil at 500 for a few
minutes until the skin is bubbling